What?
I'm sorry, my king, but we're out of time.
Welcome back everyone,
it's Charlie
This will be my full Marvel
What If Season 2 Episode 8 video
There were a whole bunch of Easter Eggs and references.
It was basically their version of Marvel's
1602 from the comics with a bunch of changes.
there's so much to unpack here.
They could have done an entire season
inside the Marvel 1602 Universe.
So if you're brand new to the channel, be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes we will be getting.
What if Season three?
So I'll talk a little bit about that after the finale.
careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the episode yet, we'll start
at the beginning, work our way through shop by show.
I talk about Easter eggs WTF moments,
starting with the episode title
What If The Avengers assembled in 1602?
Based like I said on the Marvel 1602
comics written by Neil Gaiman
originally that was written to be like an elseworlds
kind of story, like a self-contained
one off kind of thing, but they've since brought
the characters back multiple times.
They also brought the 1602 characters back during
the more modern version of Secret Wars a while ago.
we've got the live action version of Avengers six
Secret Wars coming up, maybe even Avengers five two.
If they turn secret wars into a two part movie
now, maybe we'll see some live action
versions of the 62 characters.
But at the end of this episode,
they basically reverse all the changes that happened.
so all the Marvel characters
that were stuck here in these different roles
basically got sent back to the present
and got all their memories back.
so in reality, inside the MCU, there is no current.
1602 universe
that is still existing is its own alternate universe
Dory all explained that
when we get to that part of the episode
the original Marvel 1602 universe was created
when Steve Rogers,
Captain America is sent back in time,
causing a time rift in the year 1602,
which causes all the heroes, villains,
Major Marvel characters from present day
to come into existence
during that time period in the original comics.
Eventually the rift starts
to destroy this new 1602 universe.
They try to stop it by sending
Steve Rogers back through to its present day.
Ultimately,
the watcher is granted a pocket universe in the comics
where he's allowed to keep that Marvel 1602 Universe
alive They kind of introduced that concept during
what if season one where the watcher traps infinity
Ultron in the Killmonger in their own pocket universe
that they can't escape from
They start the episode with that Marvel Studios intro,
but some special period specific
old timey music in the actual opening
scene is of Loki performing
a Shakespeare play in the Globe Theater in London.
The Globe is a real theater that's still operational
in present day,
but was around during the time of Shakespeare.
it's been featured in a lot of period movies
during that era.
the whole idea, though, is that during this time
period, Shakespeare is alive.
So like Loki is getting his plays from Shakespeare
hot off the presses, like,
I've got a fresh new play from Shakespeare
here, who he calls Will like,
my friend Will here is writing plays for me,
one that he's performing here, talking to Yorick.
The skull is Hamlet.
to be or not to be.
That is the question.
Very famous play.
Tom Hiddleston has performed Hamlet in real life.
He's performed a lot of Shakespeare's plays
in real life,
even before he became Loki inside the Marvel Universe.
During the first Thor movie.
This thing you might have
picked up on here, too,
even if you don't know Hamlet, is the play itself.
Like as he's reciting the lines
here is meant to be an Easter egg for the Thor movies
because Hamlet inspired some of the story of Loki
stealing the throne, trying to kill Odin.
in this universe.
Loki is just a regular prince.
The royal family is Thor's family.
But it's based on British history,
not on Norse mythology.
HeLa is the sitting queen.
Cate Blanchett came back to play her again.
And it's a bit of a meta Easter egg because in
real life, Cate Blanchett also played Queen Elizabeth.
The first and 1602, was right around the tail
end of her reign when King James was getting ready
to ascend the throne after her
pretty much everyone's costumes in the episode
are based on their suits
that they wore in the MCU in present day.
some of them have more Easter eggs than others baked
into the designs, particularly all the Iron Man Easter
eggs, pretty much all the characters that had powers in
the MCU still have their powers in 1602 here.
But within universe,
everyone believes that they've always lived here.
The reality has always been like this.
In the only person from the future
or another universe is Captain Carter.
Even though technically Steve Rogers
caused the accident with the time Stone
sending everybody into this sort of alternate reality,
this alternate universe.
So remember.
Even though Steve Rogers is meant to be the forerunner,
him coming back basically created
this whole alternate universe.
So none of these characters are supposed to be here.
when Captain Carter steals Loki's skull here,
he also recites a line from the play Hamlet.
Do you mind if I borrow that? That's my. Your
poor Yorick.
the other Easter egg here, the verse from Hamlet
he's reciting
Take up arms against the Sea of Troubles
is meant to be a metaphor for the actual plot
of the episode where Captain Carter and the others
take up arms to try and save this universe
by sending Steve Rogers
back to the future, reversing the damage that he caused
They flash the 1602 title card
to tell you the time period in an old timey font.
I love that.
Thor is also to board to make it through Loki's play
like even time
displaced in the past he can't stand like, No, no, no,
we don't have time for this.
I want to go have fun and drink.
pretty much
all the Marvel actors came back from the movies
to play their characters again, with a few exceptions,
like everyone who had somebody else
playing their character in previous episodes,
like Iron Man, Captain America, Steve Rogers,
they came back to play those characters again
in this episode,
but everyone else came back from the movies
to voice their character.
we see that happy.
Hogan is kind of like the Queen's attendant,
maybe like her captain of the guard,
Nick Fury, is her spymaster
because of course, he is Their crowns in the guard's
armor are based on asgardian designs
like their ones in present day, even though technically
all their traditions and the references
they make are mostly to British history.
With a few exceptions, Hello Scepter is based on Loki's
scepter from present day,
but instead of the mind stone, it's the time stone
Because of the accident
caused by Steve Rogers
during his version of Avengers Infinity War
when he was fighting Thanos in his present day,
We see the first time rift is slowly destroying
this universe is sort of like the ripple effects
of Steve Rogers original accident.
They're going to eventually
just consume this entire universe.
healing itself through the rift,
basically erasing her from existence in this universe.
they reveal Captain Carter was brought to this universe
by Scarlet Witch, who they're calling Wanda Merlin,
like she's a version of Merlin.
In this universe.
Merlin is an actual character in Marvel Comics.
He was from Camelot.
Camelot is a real place in the MCU history
they reference during the Eternals movie.
so like King Arthur,
the King Arthur mythology,
all that stuff was real inside the MCU.
Scarlet Witch uses her chaos magic
to bring Captain Carter
here to solve the mystery of the rift
and try to stop them.
She saves Loki, but fails to save HeLa.
Thor is then named King.
He briefly became king in the MCU.
He blames Captain Carter, assuming that she's cursed
because he's
kind of thick headed anime style, like he's
super thick.
In this episode, We see that happy Hogan
is also the freak in this universe to the purple lines.
He's basically like a purple version of the Hulk.
The way they play him on the show
previously during his Christmas episode,
he wondered if he'd be stuck like this forever.
Turns out it was a reference to this episode like, Yep,
you're definitely going to turn to the freak again.
in it was basically the same way that Hulk logic works,
like he has his mind, but there's still rage
based powers, so the minute he gets pissed off,
he turns into the Hulk, just like Bruce Banner.
they use the regular what if intro?
No special changes here.
The watcher ironically calls
the events of this universe a Shakespearean tragedy
because we just got done
watching Loki recite Shakespeare.
we see him in the background of the sky watching
Captain Carter escaping.
They do a bit of a needle drop moment where they reveal
that she can actually hear him narrating.
Not clear exactly why,
maybe because of their interactions during season
one in what happened in the circumstances
that brought her to this universe.
Like she's just attuned to him.
one of the other ironies of the episode
some of you probably spotted
this is a Captain Carter is British, naturally.
And this episode takes place
in this universe version of London.
In her suit is the Union Jack. It's the British flag.
when they were getting ready for season
one before they had revealed that they were calling her
Captain Carter?
I was actually calling her Captain Britain
because her suit looked more like Captain Britain suit.
when the watcher calls her a time displaced
super soldier, that's also a reference to her
time traveling in her first episode
in the original Steve Rogers, Captain America
getting stuck in the ice, first in his universe,
then winding up in present day
then also during this universe's version of Avengers
Infinity War time traveling into the past.
so becomes another time
Display super soldier again and again.
and when.
He says that there are worlds
amongst the multiverse destined to die.
But every once in a while there's a glimmer of hope.
That's a reference
to the ending of the original comic book Marvel 1602
Universe reveal Captain Carter's
basically figured out what actually happened
in this universe, even though she doesn't know
that Steve Rogers is the forerunner yet.
Like, she doesn't know exactly how it happened.
She just knows what happened.
basically the future of this universe
collided with the past in this universe.
It all kind of got mixed up together,
all because of the accident with the time
stone inside the palace,
there's a bunch of Marvel character references.
Nick Fury mentions Nebulas Observatory.
The Isle of Ego is their version of ego,
the living planet.
But like, he's just a living island,
not a full planet than happy mentions the Groot Groves.
Like Groot is the winery where they grow their grapes.
So must be really tasty. Groot flavored wine.
Scarlett, which is powerful enough to sense
that there is a forerunner,
like a time displaced person
causing all these time ribs.
But she doesn't know that it's Steve Rogers yet.
She only knows what happened.
the pretty bird that Nick Fury is whispering about
is a Black Widow reference.
But in the episode, he's
actually speaking to Captain Carter as they explain
he and Scarlett, which were trying to help her
this whole time, knowing that she was really trying
to save them all in Thor, which is being super thick,
preventing her from doing that
I didn't see the actual black Widow
during the 1602 time period.
But if you think you spotted her in the background,
just point her out in the comments
they go to Iron Man's workshop.
We see Tony Stark.
He's a ne'er do well drunk in this universe.
It doesn't seem like he's super rich,
But he's got designs for a flight suit, armor
suits all around, basically prototypes
for old timey versions of Iron Man suits.
He winds up constructing an old timey briefcase,
Iron Man armor
suit like a Mach five for Captain Carter,
powered by the time Stone.
Later in the episode.
But because it's old timey, it's more like a chest
than an actual briefcase, like a chest suit.
their little Easter eggs all around his shop.
So when the camera starts panning around,
you look over at the bottom here,
you see what looks like an Ironman Mach one helmet.
all the green fragments that they start
examining are fragments of the time stone
that broke off when Steve Rogers, Captain America,
damaged it in his fight
with Thanos in his present day
version of Avengers Infinity War.
when she says it's radioactive, that's correct.
They give off cosmic radiation
like cosmic background radiation.
the infinity stones are meant to be made
of remnant energy leftover from the Big Bang
because they are basically the remnants
of the previous version of the universe
before the Big bang
you could really get into the weeds on this
like if you do an entire video
just explaining the whole cycle of big banks.
It's based on real life scientific theory.
but in the Marvel Universe is a cycle of big banks
where basically
you have the big bang,
the universe is created or the multiverse is created.
it slowly expands and eventually contracts.
And you go through another cycle
and another big bang in another version
of the universe of the multiverse is born.
The infinity stones basically contain all the energy
of that previous version of the universe,
which is why they're so powerful.
that background,
cosmic radiation is also the same energy
that Scarlet Witch wields with her chaos magic
that was inside the hex.
That's
how she created the hex and everything inside it.
one of the other cool Iron Man Easter eggs here, too,
is that when Tony Stark creates
his chest suit, this is powered
by the time stone in the Marvel Universe.
His arc reactor is powered based on Infinity
Stone technology, But it's based on the tesseract.
The space stone.
Captain Carter makes a Back to the Future movie
reference
saying flux capacitor
when he's looking for a device that takes everything.
Iron Man essentially creates
an old timey Iron Man suit powered by the time stone.
Kind of like an Iron Man flux capacitor, helping
send Steve Rogers back to present day.
she also kind of gives him
the idea to create an arc reactor.
he sends her to Steve Rogers who believes
because of the accident that he always belonged here
and has become this universe's version of Robin Hood
called Rogers Hood with his Band of Mary Men
Robin Prince Loki, who's trying to impress the ladies
with his new Shakespeare
play that he just learned about.
The Jago that he references is from Othello.
He's basically telling them about Othello
that will his friend, quote unquote,
William Shakespeare, literally just wrote Tom
Hiddleston has also performed the Othello play on stage
when he was younger, before he became Loki.
they revealed that Steve Rogers
Merry Men are Ant-Man in Bucky.
Basically, Steve Rogers
winds up meeting Captain Carter.
And because the accident like I said, he doesn't know
that he's from the future at this point in the episode.
She doesn't know that he's the forerunner either.
they just have a couple of funny moments
about their chemistry together.
Like, even though they're from alternate universes,
they both were kind of drawn to each other.
when he says his maid Margaret died previously
because we're talking about Robin Hood references.
His maid, Margaret was kind of like the Robin Hood
maid.
Marian but also, it reminds you, Peggy Carter's actual
full name is Margaret Carter.
Peggy is just what people call her
when they're sharing the drink back at their Robin Hood
esque hideout in the tree, houses sitting by the window
is meant to be a reference to their scene back
during season one and sharing a drink in the pub
during World War Two, She talks
about being in the wrong place at the wrong time,
being a specialty of hers, like totally normal for her.
It's a reference to her time travel accident.
Also a wink at Steve Rogers being another time
display's super soldier like he literally traveled
to time a couple different times
because he was stuck in the ice.
And then the time stone sent him back into the past.
We find out that Thor's special Forces
are actually the Yellow Jackets based on the character.
But these are a squad of regular soldiers
that had just been given
yellow jacket powers in suits with Pym particles.
it's a bit of a reference to that Hydra plot So, like,
Daring Cross was going to sell the Yellowjacket
suit in Hydra to them for a fortune
so that they could create an army of beings like this.
Ant-Man, Cole's Happy a freak,
a reference to his comic book freak persona in Powers.
there are bunch of really cool references
and Easter eggs during the actual fight scene too.
They kind of bacon here, particularly Steve Rogers
in Peggy Carter or Captain Carter
using the shield,
passing it back and forth between each other.
remember, in this universe,
he's never had a vibranium shield in this time period.
Or he thinks that he hasn't had a vibranium shield
because he doesn't know he's from the future.
but it is weird
how good he is using it without having used it before.
Like, wow, you're a natural with this.
I wonder why when Bucky says Barton sends his regards
firing the crossbow, they make it sound
kind of like happy Hogan in this universe
killed Hawkeye before the events of the episode.
Pick up. So R.I.P.
Press to pay respects to Hawkeye,
then Happy rolls out the destroyer armor
They're using more like their secret weapon
they reveal in this universe.
Happy also hates Tony Stark.
Like, how dare you suggest that I would ever be friends
with him?
Captain Carter surrenders, and they take her back
to the Tower of London, which is a real place.
If you haven't been, it's
actually pretty cool to visit.
they reveal in this reality,
Red Skull is their executioner.
They don't give him any speaking lines in the episode.
But he does get a cool fight scene later when she
starts arguing with the watcher, they repeat the line.
What if what if,
like several times is the name of the show?
They say the thing inside the thing.
Like they go for Meme.
What if you die?
What if? What if? What if?
He said it.
He said.
We learned that Bruce Banner Hulk
is in the cell next to hers.
The iron mask he's
wearing is a parody of the man in the Iron Mask story.
But the Iron Mask itself
is also designed to look like the Iron Man mask.
One helmet probably made by Tony Stark in this reality
who sold it to the crown
when she apologizes to Bruce saying sorry for
this is a callback to Black Widow
forcing him to transform back in Avengers
Age of Ultron, like she pushes him off the cliff.
she basically does a version of that
like tricks the guards into forcing him
to transform into Hulk form and uses him to escape.
when they're leaping across the sky,
you can see the watcher seeing them in the background.
then Iron Man, still a lousy drunk, gives Bruce Banner
a bunch of grain
alcohol and reveals his briefcase
or his chest version of the Iron Man.
Mark five suit designed to be powered
by the time stone.
Steve Rogers returns with the shield
wearing it on his back like he did with his
in present day, even though he doesn't remember
present day when they go to the throne room.
The reason why the rift opens there amongst
the ceiling is because Steve Rogers is there
and he is the focal point.
He's the reason for the risks in the first place.
they reveal in this universe.
Thor also gave Loki Mjolnir,
but Loki lost it like he's useless in this universe.
we see that Thor is calling his vibranium sword
that he got as a gift from this universe.
This version of Black Panther,
the King of Wakanda, the all Father.
I'm assuming that Odin was also the sitting king
before Hella took the throne here.
though, because they're based more on British history.
They didn't call this version of Odin, the old father.
It seems like he has all the same powers
in this universe, but he's just channeling
his lightning through the sword,
like the sword itself is not generating the lightning.
we finally get a Hulk versus Hulk fight.
When Bruce Banner fights Happy Hogan
the freak the pipes are calling
reference is a callback to the song. Danny boy.
When Iron Man is breaking out his suit,
he references starting an industrial revolution
like in real life,
in Captain Carter activates the briefcase armor
and they reveal Steve Rogers is the forerunner like
he was in the comics, basically saying their goodbyes
before he activates the device for her,
sending him back to the present, saving this universe
and basically erasing all these versions
of the Marvel characters from existence.
when they say in another reality,
they do get their happy ending, that's just a reference
to the ending from Avengers Endgame, where he goes
back in time to stay with his Peggy Carter.
end, they reveal once Peggy Carter fixes everything,
like all these Marvel characters
are erased from existence,
she's actually stuck here but is back to normal.
So it's more like it was during actual real life.
1602 we get a real quick tag scene
where supreme strange portals
into the pub in her universe
to recruit her to his multiverse Avengers team.
Like just you wait
till I tell you what I got ready for you.
whatever.
That finale is going to wind up being,
just like we did with Cordy at the end of her episode
where he showed up to recruit her.
we also get a to be continued title card
in old timey font,
which we haven't gotten before on the show.
they flew.
We don't have to wait too long to see them
actually pay this often.
Find out what's going on in the actual finale.
Episode nine is going to happen tomorrow.
So of course my video will post
after they release that.
we don't know too much
about what's actually going on in the finale.
Like, there's a lot of scenes of Thanos attacking them.
He has the Infinity gantlet.
It might be based on the accident,
the Steve Rogers cause like the time displacement
that he caused with the time, Stone
might have also thrown Thanos into another reality.
And that might have something to do with all the chaos
that's going on.
was the a version of Rocket here,
a bunch of other characters.
So we'll see who the actual new main
villain is in the finale.
Overall, it was a great episode.
It was one of my favorite from this season.
They could have done an entire season.
Like I said in this Marvel 1602 universe,
there were so many Easter eggs, so many references,
if you spotted any in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
is one of those episodes
you have to watch like three or four times
just to catch everything,
even though it's only like 25, 30 minutes long.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
My episode nine video will post tomorrow.
Be sure to enable alerts from my channel
so you don't miss that.
Click here for that video.
Update the link as soon as I posted and click here
for all my other what if episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!